พี่แดนแดนแต่นั้นแต่ดัดแต่รักแต่แรดแต่แด
แต่
เราจะไม่สวัสดีใช่ไหมคะตัวเองกำลังทำอะไร
ก็พูดเตรียมเรากำลังทำอะไรครับเรากำลังรำ
ค่ะ
กำลังรำ
คุกกรุ่นเรียมเราเป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชาย
ครับร่ำเป็นผู้หญิงค่ะ
ส่วนเอกครู S
เอกวันนี้เป็นผู้ชายมีหนวดนี่แล้วก็ชุด
ผู้ชายแล้วก็รำผู้ชายบ้างแต่ข้างล่างจะ
เป็นผู้หญิง
สวัสดีค่ะตัวเอง
ครับครับนักเรียน
วันนี้ครูเอ๋จะพูดเป็นครูผู้ชายนะครับ
ได้เลยค่ะคุณคนรุน่คุณครูจะเปิดเอ๋นะครับ
ถ้าเราไม่มีเราเป็นผู้หญิงกับผู้หญิงวัน
นี้ครูเอกก็จะเปลี่ยนเป็นผู้ชายหล่อไหม
ครับหล่อมากเลยค่ะพี่เอ๋
อย่าคิ้ว
เรื่องมาก
โอ้โหเหมือนเหมือนผู้ชายเหมือนผู้ชายเลย
ค่ะคุณเอ๋อีกว่ากูเอกเป็นผู้ชายดีกว่านะ
ก็เห็นคะวันนี้ที่เรามาเจอกัน
เป็นวันอะไรคะ
คุณเรียมคูสกูเรียนรู้สึกไม่สบายใจไหม
เวลาพูดครับครับโอเคค่ะ
ยังดูเก๋แล้วเหมือนผู้ชายพูดครับโอเค
ได้วันนี้เห็นจะพูดครับนะคะถ้าเป็นผู้ชาย
เวลาผู้ชายพูดก็พืชครับผู้หญิงพูดๆค่ะค่ะ
คะผู้ชายก็ครับวันนี้เราสองคนใส่ชุดไทย
เนี่ยนะคะ r-one อะไรก่อนวันอะไรครับครู
เรียม
วันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
วันอังคาร
น่ะ
วันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
วันที่
24 ค่ะ
วันที่ 24 นะครับแล้ววันคลานแหนบเดือนวัน
ที่ 24 เดือนอะไรครับเดือน
พฤษภาคมค่ะ
เดือนพฤษภาคมปีค.ศอะไรครับมีข้อสอ
ปี
2022 ค่ะ
2022 นะครับปีพตอะไรครับปีพตต
[เพลง]
2565 ค่ะ
2565 ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงครับตอนนี้
11:00 น 5 นาทีค่ะ
11:05 น
ครูครูแจง of  brake โคร and เดรียมครู
เรียมคะลับครูเตรียมครับบบรอเรือเยอะนะ
นี่เนี่ยวันนี้วันนี้ทำไมครูเรียมกับครู
เอ๋ใส่ชุดเสื้อผ้าไทย
ผู้หญิงเสื้อผู้ชาย
เพราะว่าครูเรียมจะพาคุณครูเอ๋ไปเซิ้ง
บั้งไฟ
ไปเซิงบั้งไฟยโสธรอยู่ที่นี่ค่ะ
อาหารยโสธร
จุดบั้งไฟค่ะ
ง้อจุดบั้งไฟทำไมต้องจุดบั้งไฟ
เดี๋ยวได้ได้ยินว่าเวลาจุดบั้งไฟเขาต้อง
มีรำใช่ไหมที่ตอนเปิดเนี่ยสุเรียมให้เขว
ลำที่เหล้ารัมกันก็คือเรากำลังลำ
ซิ่งแห่บั้งไฟ
อ๋ออ๋อมีบ้างไก่
หลายขบวนแห่บั้งไฟ
ใช่ค่ะ
ก็จะมี
1 นางรำ
หลายๆคน
เอาเข้ามีแต่ผู้หญิงเนาะ
หน่อยค่ะคุณเอ๋ผู้ชายนิดหน่อยผู้ชายจะแบก
บางไผ่ใช่ไหมคะ
ผู้ชายเราไป
ทำไมเขาต้องจุดบั้งไฟล์อ่ะเตรียมอือเพราะ
ว่ามีเรื่องเล่าต่อๆกันมาตั้งแต่เมื่อ
ก่อนค่ะที่เล่าต่อๆกันมาเรื่อยๆเขาเขา
เล่าว่ายังไง
เขาแล้วว่ามีขยะขันค่าค่ะคุณเอ๋
คันไม่ใช่คันคันค่าถ้าเกิดแบบนี้ที่บ้าน
ตัวนี้ว่าอะไรคะอ่ะค่ะมีโค้ก
คางคกภาษาไทยกลางครั้งคอนแต่ว่าเรียกว่า
ค่ะ
ใช่แต่โคตรที่อยู่ภาคอีสานของประเทศไทยนะ
คะจะเรียกว่าเรียกว่าอะไร
คันค่าคันค่า
ค่ะโค้งสวยไหมเนี่ย
ไม่สวยค่ะคิ้วสวย
คือ
ใช่แต่ว่าใจดีนะคะพญาคันคากใจดี
แค่เรียกอ่ะเรียกว่าขันข้างคนไทยเลือกภาค
กลางเลขคางคกแต่มีคำว่าพญาหมายความว่ายัง
ไงพญาคันข้างแปลว่าเป็นหัวหน้าหัวหน้าของ
คางคกไม่
ใช่ตัวใหญ่
ใช่คนอีสานถ้าเกิดเห็นอะไรตัวใหญ่ๆก็จะ
ชอบเรียกว่าค่ะยาก็คือตัวใหญ่มากๆซื้อ
ท่าช้างตัวใหญ่ก็พญาช้างใช่
อนิดคางคกหรือว่าคันค่าตัวใหญ่ก็เลยเรียก
ว่าพญามาฆ่ากันนะกูอ่อนหนวดออกแล้วครับ
โอเค
พญาคำค่าใจดีมากค่ะใจดีมากๆค่ะครูเอ๋
ก็ช่วยช่วยคนช่วยคนหลายๆคน
แต่ว่า
ช่วยอะไรอ่ะ
ช่วยคน
ฟิล์มก็คือก็ไม่แน่ใจเหมือนกันนะคะว่า
ช่วยอะไรแต่ว่าเรื่องที่เขาเล่าต่อๆกันมา
บอกแค่ว่าพญาคันคากใจดีคนก็เลยไปคุยคุย
คุยด้วยหลายๆคน
แล้วมันจะเกี่ยวกับบั้งไฟยังไงกูเรียม
เกี่ยวกับบ้างไปเพราะว่าจะมี
อีกพญานึง
อยู่บนอยู่บนสวรรค์
อยู่บนสวรรค์นี้ก็คือข้างบนใช่ไหมให้ข้าง
บนชื่อชื่ออะไรชื่อพญาแถน
ชื่อพญาแผนมีรูปพญาแถนไหมครับ
นี่เลยค่ะพญาแถน
พญาแห่งเทวดา
ใช่ค่ะเป็นเทวดาเตรียมว่าได้ไหมแต่ว่า
อย่างนี้ได้มั้ยไม่ได้ไม่ได้เป็นเทวดา
นั้นเทวดาของต่างประเทศ
เทวดาไทยไม่มีกลมๆถ้าอ้ายเป็นเทวดาอยู่บน
สวรรค์
แล้วก็สวัสดิ์ขนาดพญาแถนเนี่ยทำหน้าที่
อะไร
พญาแถนทำหน้าที่
ให้ฝนตก
หรือว่าไม่ให้ฝนตกก็ได้
เป็นเทวดาที่ช่วยใช่มีเกิดฝนตกใช่ทาน
อาหารใช่แล้ว
ตอนนั้นถ้าถ้าเป็นภาคกลางก็เรียกพระพิรุณ
ก็ดูแลเรื่องฝนถ้าไม่ให้ฝนตก
[เพลง]
พักของทางบ้านครูเรียมก็พญาแถน
พญาแถนเอ๊ะแล้วค่ายาแขนให้ฝนตกพยานคัน
ข้างอยู่บนโลกเป็นเพื่อนกันไหมไม่ได้เป็น
เพื่อนกันค่ะคุณเอ๋
พญาแถนเห็นคน
หลายๆคนไปคุยคุยคุยกับไข่อาคารค่าแล้วก็
ไม่คุยคุยคุยกับพญาแถน
พญาแถนก็เลยโกรธลืมพญาแผน
ใช่
หมายความว่าเมื่อก่อนตอนพญาคันข้างยังไม่
มาที่ตรงนั้นช่างคนก็จะพญาถ้ารักก็คุยใช่
ๆแปลว่าพอมีพญาลูกค้ามาคนก็ลืมพญาแถนแล้ว
ก็ไปคุยกับพญากันค่าอ๋อเหมือนกับได้คน
ใหม่ก็ลืม
คนจำเก่าๆใช้ขึ้นไปลืมเพื่อนเก่าและอัน
นี้ไม่ใช่เพื่อนได้อะไรนะคนมีอำนาจไม่ใช่
คนด้วยพญาพญาคันข้างมีมีพลังมีอำนาจใหม่
ก็ลืมพญาแถนชายาแถมรู้สึกอะไรค่ะพญาแถน
ไม่รู้สึกโหลด
ขี้ใจช่วยนะมากๆ
พญาแถนทำยังไงพญาแถนก็ไม่ให้ฝนตก
ไม่ให้ฝนตก
เวลาก่อนนะผมข้าวได้ไหมไม่ได้ค่ะคุณเอ๋ฝน
ไม่ตก
และก็จะแล้งดินแตก
ปลูกข้าวปลูกข้าวแบบนี้ไม่ได้
ปลูกต้นไม้ไม่ได้พลังงานไปคะปลาก็ตาย
หรือก็ไม่มีอาหารกิน
ใช่ค่ะ
ไอ้เนี่ยอาหารกินชาวบ้านก็เลยไปคุยคุยคุย
กับพญาคันข้างบอกว่าฝนไม่ตกเลยเพราะว่า
พญาแถนโปรดมากๆตอนนี้
ทำไมไม่ไปคุยพยาธิแท้นขอฝนตก
ไม่รู้นะค่ะไม่รู้เหมือนกันกูเองก็สงสัย
พญาแถนให้ฝนตกแต่ชาวบ้านไม่คุยกับพญาแถน
ออกไปอย่าแทนหนีไปด้วยเพราะว่าพญาแถมโกรธ
อยู่ในคะก่อนอยู่ไม่
อานาพญานั้นบ่ไม่คุย
ใช่ได้คุยกับพยานคาดพญาคันคากทำยังไงพญา
คันคากก็เลย
จะไปคุยกับพญาแถนขี่บนสวรรค์
พญาคันคากขึ้นสวรรค์ได้
ขึ้นไปไม่ได้แต่ว่ามีวิธีนะคะกูกูเอกทำ
ยังไงคะก็ให้ปลวกค่ะเก๋รู้จักพวกไหมปลวก
ปลวกตัวเล็กๆ
ใช่ผัวเขาจะสร้างจอมปลวกขึ้นไปสูงๆ
อันนี้เป็นจอมปวด
ให้ขึ้นสูงจนถึงสวรรค์ใช่
ต้นไปเจอพญาแถน
แล้วค่ะหยัดเข่นฆ่าก็ขึ้ออกไปบนจอมปลวก
ใช่ค่ะ
ไม่ได้ไปคนเดียวนะคะเอ้าไปกับใครไปกับ
ปลวกไปกับปลวกแล้วก็ไปดับ nang ป่อง
ขยะแมงป่องใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะยาปอดก็บอก
ว่าพญาแมงป่องนะแมงป่องตัวใหญ่ๆนะคะไม่
แต่งตัวเล็กๆมีพญาแมงป่องพาทีมไปมีอะไร
อีกอะไรอีกค่ะแล้วก็มีพญาต่อ
มีพญาต่อไปด้วยใช่แล้วก็ต่อทั้งทีมไปชน
หมดแล้วค่ะแล้วก็ไปเช่าพญาคันคากพวกมากสิ
มีพูดเยอะ
คึดท้องไงคะเพราะว่าพญาแถนก็เก่งนะพญา
แห่งต้องมีพลังเยอะมากๆ
ตกลงพญาคันคากไปคุยต่อไปไปสู้กันสุดท้าย
ก็ไปสู้กัน
สู้กัน
คือนักเรียนประหยัดแผนไม่ฟังนะคะพวกลงกด
กดคนโปรดพญาคันคากด้วยพูดไม่ฟังตอนนี้
เป็นสู้แล้วต้องสู้กันอ่ะคนชนะก็จะให้ให้
ทำอะไรก็ได้ถ้าใช่โอเคหน้าไปเจอกันแล้วก็
พญาคันข้างก็ขึ้นจอมปวดใช่มั้ยยอมปวดฟัน
ข้าวแล้วก็ขึ้นขึ้นไปเนี้ยกินตอบปลวกไปจน
ถึงสวรรค์
ใช่ก็มีที่พยายามต่อขยันต่อพญาอะไรนะพญา
ปลวกพญาปลวกยาต่อพญาแมงป่อง
ณหอธรรมใบที่สว่างชายแล้วก็ไปสู้ค่ะยาแผล
ชายเอกพญาแผนองค์เดียวไม่พญาแถนองค์เดียว
ไหมใช่ขึ้น
พญาหันมีเพื่อนมั้ยมีมีนะคะนักเรียนที่
เนี่ยฟังมาไม่มีค่ะไม่มีเพื่อนไม่มีเก็บ
ตัวดาวเป็นเพื่อนเหรอค่ะ
ไม่รู้นะคะจะได้ยินมาแค่ไปสู้กับพญาแถน
องค์เรียว
ได้แล้วก็ไข่อาคารค่าทางพญาคันคากก็เลย
เป็นคนชนะ
ก็มีตัวต่อต่อยพญาแถนมีแมงป่องใส่ใช่ไหม
เบอร์พญาคันข้างชนะชนะแล้วเนี่ยเออ
เกิดอะไรขึ้นคะหลังจากผู้ชนะแล้วพญาแถน
กับพญาคันคากก็เลยสัญญากัน
สัญญากันว่าพยานแหน่
จะทำให้ฝนตก
ก็
แล้ว
ฝนตกเมื่อไหร่อย่างไร
นี่ก็ตกตอนไหนเมื่อไหร่อย่างไรตอนไหนคุย
ถามเยอะเลยค่ะยาแทนก็เลยบอกว่า
ถ้าเมื่อไหร่ที่อยากให้ฝนตก
ก็ส่งส่งอะไรสักอย่างขึ้นไปบนฟ้าบอกพญา
แถนพญาแถนจะได้รู้
ส่งไร่ร้ายได้ไหมไม่มีลายอีเมลไม่ได้
ออออ่าโทรศัพท์ไม่ได้อ่ะค่ะ hue ไม่ได้ก็
ได้ส่งอะไรคะบ้านก็เลย
ส่งบั้งไฟขึ้นไป
ก็เล่นสูตร
พญาแสนนอนหลับ
บั้งไฟขึ้นมา
อดโอเค
คนไม่มีน้ำโอเคฝนตก
ใช่แบบนั้นเลย
ทำไมต้องจุดแบงค์ไฟใช่แล้วค่ะเรื่องก็
เป็นอย่างเนี้ยเอ๊าแล้วฝนตกพอแล้วหรือยัง
ไม่พอ
ยังงานแผนจะรู้ได้อย่างไร
พญาแทนก็บอกคนว่าเวลาที่อยากให้ฝนหยุดฝน
เน็ตหยุดจบตอน
หมอชาวบ้านเกี่ยวข้าวเสร็จแล้วชาวบ้านก็
จะเล่นว่า
เป็นว่าข้าวบ้านก็จะรอยลอยๆขึ้นไป
พญาแถนพระจังรู้
ฝนหยุด
พญาแถนเห็นว่าปั๊บแปลว่าพอแล้วให้ใช้
เป็นเฝ้าอะไรนะครับเข้าจุนอาเน๊าะเป็นว่า
ถือว่าอะไรก็ได้ต้องว่าวจุฬาผู้หญิงว่า
เอาอะไรก็ได้ว่าหลายๆแบบแต่ว่าทางอีสานจะ
มีว่าเข้าจุฬาแล้วเขาก็จะมีเสียง
ว่าจะมีเสียงนะคะของทางอีสานเขาจะมีเสียง
เขาเรียกว่าเสียง slow เวลาเล่นว่าน่าจะ
มีเสียงตึง
ตึงบนฟ้า Out
อุ้ยทำไมมีเสียง
พอเขาถามก็ใส่อะไรเข้าไปที่โดนลมเวลาโดน
ลมแล้วมีเสียงใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
ไม่รู้อ๋อพี่เอ๋เวลาเร่งบ้างแล้วมันจะได้
ยินเสียงไหม
เออกูเห็นเล่นว่าวตอนอายุ 8 ขวบกูดิ
นานว่าจำไม่ได้จำไม่ได้นะตั้งแต่อายุแปด
ขวบเล่นว่าวแล้วไม่เคยเล่นอีกแล้วอ่ะทำ
งาน 8-9 ขวบคะเพราะว่าเวลาเล่นว่าวแล้ว
ครูเอกเวลาลมแรงๆน่ะเป็นเวลาก่อนฝนตกและ
คู่เอกเป็นเล่นตอนนั้นน่ะพ่อแม่ก็กลัวฟ้า
จะผ่าเปรี้ยงก็เลยห้ามเล่นเว้าอั้มเล่น
ป่าวเลยไม่ได้เล่นอีก
ก็คิดว่าคนน่าจะมีอะไรเต็มที่เวลาลมผ่าน
แล้วก็จะมีเสียงดังใช่ไงไอ้หน้ารหัสช่วง
ที่ทำ
นาทำนาเสร็จเรียบร้อยเกี่ยวข้าวเสร็จ
เรียบร้อยแล้วเราก็จะวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่ง
เล่นว่างที่ท้องนาได้ที่ทุ่งนาตอนแล้ว
วิ่งได้ก็แปลงบอกพญาแท้นไม่ต้องมีฝนแล้ว
ก็ตอนนี้จะต้องออกข้าวไปต่างอ่ะช่วยนะ
ต้องเอาข้าวไปตากก็
ให้ร้อนใช่ให้ข้าวแห้งแห้งๆใช่ค่ะ
งั้นฉันค่าหลังจากที่สู้เสร็จทำสัญญา
เสร็จโต๊ะจบงาน
ฝนจะตกเมื่อไหร่ฝนจะตกเมื่อไหร่ชาวก็จะ
เริ่มทำนาได้เมื่อไหร่น่ะมีอะไรที่ชาวนา
จะได้ยินหรือรู้ไหมคะจะมีเสียงอะไร
จะมีเสียงกบค่ะ
กบนี้เป็นลูกน้องพญาทันข้างไหม
กบไม่ใช่ใครไม่อยากต่างชาติน่าจะเป็นนะ
ยังบ้านให้ดูอกจริงๆจริงๆครั้งคกด้วยครู
เรียมคางคกก็ร้องค่ายฉันก็ร้อง
อบก็ร้อง
อร์ดอ๊อดๆ
ออดๆวันหนึ่งอ่างปะ
มึงอ่านก็ร้อง
[เพลง]
จะพูด
จบอ่ะและเตรียมปะต่อตอนที่ผู้เรียนได้ยิน
น่ะคือครั้งโค้กอ๋อ
นั่นแหละ
คือครูเอ๋น่ะไม่ไม่รู้ว่าเสียเงินเนี่ย
เสียงอะไรแต่ว่าที่คอนโดที่เนี่ยจะมีไม่
มีกบจะมีครั้งคบจะมีคางคกที่นี้มีอยู่วัน
นึงที่ฝนตก
หน่อยแล้วก็ฝนแล้วก็ได้ยินจากอาจ
ๆครูเอกก็กินโอ้แถวนี้มีกบแต็กยามอ่ะที่
คอนโด V ยามเวลาขับรถรถเข้ารถออกเนี่ยมี
มิสเตอร์ยามก็บอกคุณมันไม่ใช่กบพญาคันคาด
กันขาดที่ไหน
เข้าใจก็บอกค้างคกเสียงคางคกอาจๆๆ
กูเอกก็คิดกบอือมาแล้วฝนก็ตก
ตกหุ่นนานมาก
ใช่ค่ะเรื่องนี้ก็เลยแบบเหมือนมีสัญญาณ
อยู่ 3 อย่างที่จะบอกว่า
ตอนนี้ชาวนาอยากคำนา
อยากให้ฝนตกก็จะจุดบางไผ่จุดบังใส่เป็น
บอกพญาแถนบอกว่าฝนตกฝนตกลงมาได้แล้วแล้ว
ก็น้ำยังไม่พอตกอีกนะตกอีกนะกะๆๆๆ
กบแล้วก็คางคกร้องก็จะบอกว่าฝนกำลังจะตก
ลงมาแล้ว
แล้วก็ฝนหยุดก็เป็นเลนส์เว้าใช่สัญญาณที่
3 ก็คือฝนหยุดก็คือเล่นวาวบอกว่าฝนหยุด
ได้แล้ว
คุณ
ครูเรียมแต่ได้ยินว่าเวลาที่จุดบั้งไฟ
บ้าง LINE น่ะมีแข็งไปกันใช่
จูงที่สุดก็แปลว่าไปปลุกพญาแถน
ช่องพูดคุยใส่ชุดชายเนี่ยเพราะว่าผู้ชาย
เนี่ยเวลาแบกบั้งไฟผู้หญิงอ่ะรำใช่ไหมคะ
ถ้าบั้งไฟไปจุดเนี่ยนะถ้าแพ้เกิดอะไรขึ้น
วูถ้าเกิดถ้าเกิดบ้างไฟของครูเอ๋จุดลบ
ขึ้นไปสูงๆคนก็จะไม่รู้ว่าฉันนั้นเก่งมาก
กว่าฉันนะคะ a ชั้นละแต่ถ้าเกิดบางไฟของ
คู๋จุดแล้ว
จุดแล้วไม่ขึ้น
อันนี้คืออันนี้คือฐานบ้างไปทหารถ้าเกิด
จุดแล้วบั้งไฟยังอยู่ที่ฐานที่ใส่อยู่
ไม่ขึ้นไปบนฟ้าผู้นี้ก็จะโดนเกิดมั้ย
ระเบิดนี้มีระเบิดนะคะมีเราเปิดบางครั้ง
ไม่ตู้ตรงนี้
ๆกูแพ้กูเอ๋แท้กูเอกก็จะโดนจับมาลงโคลน
โห
กับตัวเองมันลงโคลนเลือกยังมีน้ำอยู่นิด
หน่อยใช่ไหมๆค่ะมีน้ำฝนนิดหน่อยไม่อาจจะ
ปลูกต้นไม้ปลูกข้าวไม่ได้นะคะถ้าโดนจับไป
ครู่โกนก็ไม่ไปแข่งดีกว่า
กูเรียนรู้สึกสนุกใช่ไหมคะนี้ใช่ค่ะสนุก
เพราะเรียงชอบรำรำแห่บั้งไฟก็อยากผู้
เรียนเดี๋ยวทำไมปีเนี้ยปีนี้ไม่ได้ไปค่ะ
ทีนี้ทำงานทำงานทำงานค่ะ
ก็ชวนเลยไป
เคยค่ะอยากปีเลย
ที่ประหาสารคามก็มีแล้วก็จังหวัดในภาค
อีสานนะคะ
จังหวัดในภาคอีสานมีแห่บั้งไฟและหลาย
จังหวัด
ก็มียโสธรมหาสารคาม
เราก็มีขวัญกาฬสินธุ์ขอนแก่น
หูในหลายๆจังหวัดค่ะอ๋อก็คุยกันว่า
จังหวัดดี
ฝนตกทุกจังหวัดไม่ใช่มีหลายจังหวัดที่จุด
บังใส่แห่บั้งไฟใช่แต่ว่าที่คนรู้จักเยอะ
ๆก็จะมีที่ยโสธร
ค่ะใช่เริ่มใกล้จะชวนพูห์เอมา
ใช่
ชวนนักเรียนเนี่ยมาเบิก
ต้องปีหน้านะคะคุณเดี๋ยวปีหน้าใช่ค่ะ
เสร็จแล้ว
ปีหน้าเดือนพฤษภาคมค่ะ
หมา
เดินวันที่เท่าไหร่ค่ะประมาณวันที่ 10
11 ถึง 16 นะคะประมาณนะคะเพราะว่าอาจจะ
เธอเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนไปไม่เหมือนกัน
ค่ะซื้อแลสนใจน่าสนใจค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็
ก็รู้จักเนาะรู้จักตำนานเกี่ยวกับการจุด
บั้งฝ่ายร้านจุดบั้งไฟ
ทำไมมีเราเรียกประเพณี
ประธานอีจุดบั้งไฟนะคะหรือประเพณีแห่บั้ง
ไฟของทางอีสานทำไมต้องจุดบึ้ม
เพราะว่าข้างบนมีพญาแผนอยากให้ฝนตกก็ต้อง
จุดบั้งไฟบอกพญาแถนนัดคณะเวียนมาเมืองไทย
อยากไปดูนะคะกอล์ฟที่ครูเรียมบ่เดือน
พฤษภาคมวันที่
11-16 นะคะได้ค่ะมีการวัดเตรียมเปิด
YouTube ก็ได้ว่าร้องเก็บ Festival มั้ง
ภาษาอังกฤษ
เอาไว้น้ำหมดแล้วใช่ไหมคะคุณเอ๋
ครูเอกก็จะไปแล้วจะเป็นผู้หญิงเต็มตัวนะ
เอาล่ะเรายังลำลาลาไปแล้วนะคะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะ
เราไปแล้วค่า
ในแต่ The แปล . แตน
stands เดี๋ยวไม่จบอ่ะ